star wars episode 2 Attack of the Clones
is once again written and directed by
George Lucas and if you guys didn't know
I'm in the middle of covering every
single Star Wars movie once a month
until episode 7 in December that's
including the Clone Wars animated film
last month on May 4th
I reviewed Phantom Menace you guys dug
it I'm back for more with attack of the
clones yeah and just as a warning just
like the Phantom Menace I'm gonna be
talking in detail here so if you've
never seen Attack of the Clones
I'm gonna be spoiling some plot elements
and now you've been warned let's talk
about this thing so the blow that was
attack of the clones was a little bit
lessened simply because we had already
seen Phantom Menace so he sort of knew
what to expect but there was still a lot
of fan anticipation going into this
movie hoping just hoping that maybe
Lucas had listened to some of the
complaints with the first film and in
one small specific way he did he
lessened jar jar's involvement in this
film a lot he's in like one or two
scenes we'll talk more about him later
but for the most part it's the same type
of movie that Phantom Menace was a
gigantic green screen blue screen
disaster with even worse dialogue milady
so sorry what most people expected
episode 2 to be about was Anakin getting
darker closer to that dark side
discovering that evil side of him but
it's really just a romance he runs into
Padme and they fall in love together and
that's essentially what Attack of the
Clones is about now one of my biggest
complaints with the Phantom Menace was
that the Jedi Council didn't do anything
they just sat around in a room and
talked while everyone else did all the
hard stuff now in the first scene in the
film there's an attempt on Padme life
and her decoy gets blown up now she
suspects that Count Dooku is behind this
assassination attempt and Mace Windu
instantly denies this saying he was once
a Jedi he says it's just not in Dooku's
character to commit a crime like that
now let me get this straight if Dooku
was once a Jedi does that mean that you
can suddenly not be a Jedi and just kind
of quit being a Jedi if that were so
wouldn't that mean
your ideals have changed and that maybe
it is in his character to be bad mace
windu all-powerful Jedi who's really
fucking dumb one of the things that
really bothered me about episode 1 and
episode 2 was the casting choices made
by George Lucas for the character of
Anakin let's face it Jake Lloyd was
awful and once again Hayden Christensen
is terrible but I don't know who to
blame is that the script is that the
actors is it both what his hit but I've
been told that I have some rare footage
apparently my crack team of me
has discovered footage of George Lucas
discovering Hayden Christensen let's
observe let's decide maybe there's a
happy tree a little happy trees yes
who's this kid I like this look I'm so
taken by his acting ability since dark
unrest on his boy could he be my akan
someone really needs to call the
production team at the show and tell
them and replace that dummy with CGI
come on slappy old buddy oh look at how
he so beautifully antagonizes that dummy
he seems to be perfectly encapsulating
the inks of being a child oh my god yes
goosebumps kid
for Anakin
hi yes that's my Anakin I got that evil
stare I'm loving it huh oh boy I can't
wait to start writing this but first I
need to approve the new effects added to
the special editions oh boy I hope they
got that cantina scene right know what
the funny thing is his acting really
hasn't gotten that better since Night of
the Living dummy part three on the
goosebumps TV show so anyway this
assassin is after Padme and rather than
just fill her room with gas as she's
sleeping or shoot her or something a
little droid cuts holes into the glass
and drops worms like into her room
killer worms worst assassin ever I mean
worse
what Anakin and obi-wan stop these worms
just in time which leads to a chase the
chase is okay even though it's like this
glossy video game like CGI environment
that you just can't really take
seriously and there's a part where
Anakin jumps out of a car and obi-wan is
like I hate when he does that
I mean does that happened a lot ranek
and just jumps out of cars from like
really high places plummets down
Khorasan and lands perfectly on the
enemy vehicle is that what obi-wan hates
that he does like what is what does that
actually mean this chase eventually
leads them to a mosque Eisley cantina
like club there's one really good scene
in here where obi-wan Jedi Mind Tricks a
guy to stop being addicted to death
sticks whatever those are
that was a good scene I like that once
they capture this assassin she is just
about to tell them who hired her and a
toxic dart gets into her neck and Jango
Fett blasts off from really far away now
if this guy is so on top of things
that he can shoot this girl from however
many yards away why didn't he just
assassinate Padme I guarantee if Jango
Fett had been there he wouldn't have
used worms the scenes that follow show
us that George Lucas is using this same
technique he did in Phantom Menace to
give us information people are just
walking around in boring blue screen
rooms in which they give us exposition
and things we need to know that's all it
is just a whole bunch of scenes people
walking around going oh yes yes oh
that's interesting
oh what's this all about hmm well I
heard that there was a
planet that once but it seems to be
struck from the records I don't
understand this Yoda and these
younglings please show us oh you did it
magically thank you very much that's
that's very helpful if there's just one
thing that Lucas should have gotten
right with this movie it's the deep dark
unrest that's boiling inside of the
character of Anakin but he seems to
confuse that with being a whiny brat
because that's all Anakin is in this
entire movie a constant never-ending
complainer he's overly critical he never
listens he doesn't understand it's not
fair obi-wan never lets me do this
obi-wan never lets me do that also in
this film Anakin has major creeperface
like every time
Padme is nearby the guy looks like he's
about to assault her so obi-wan then
sends Anakin on a journey with Padme to
protect her alone now Jedi's apparently
are forbidden to love as this idea was
introduced an attack of the clones
Jedi's can never bang they can't did
nono love as bad so how are they
supposed to fucking procreate like what
what does that mean how do Jedi's
procreate if they can't love they just
look for people to breed with that's so
dumb how do you create more of your kind
you just find people and teach them I
guess you can never have children though
or maybe you're allowed to have children
as long as you don't love your mate and
George Lucas you're making everything
awful with this writing but you have to
accept it because that's what George
Lucas wrote so Jedi's are forbidden to
love so why would you send Anakin on
basically the most romantic mission ever
in which they have candlelight dinners
and sit by the fireplace and talk and
have picnics in the most beautiful
romantic location you could possibly
imagine oh and of course Padme changes
her outfit in like every single scene
and her outfits get increasingly more
revealing as the film goes on to the
point where she basically looks like an
exotic dancer she is asking for it from
Anakin but she's like no I can't do it
because I'm a senator senators aren't
allowed to do anything that's not
senator Lee also if Anakin is trying to
not attract attention to himself as
being Padme his bodyguard
wouldn't he try to hide the
Padawan braid that he has that shows
that he's still training under a Jedi so
obi-wan makes it to this planet Kamino
that he's been searching for it seems to
be almost entirely a water planet it
looks really cool but when he gets there
he learns of a clone army that's been
created under someone called Master
sifo-dyas this plot that's introduced
that's never really explored again ever
actually somehow this clone army is
being created with no one knowing about
it he just shows up at this random
planet they expect him and they only
have a clone army of CGI clone troopers
that by the way our completely CGI is
just stated not a single human clone
trooper was used in this movie not one
and I cannot go without mentioning the
next scene which contains possibly the
most stilted romantic dialogue these
ears have ever heard I hate sand it's
rough and irritating and it gets
everywhere what is with the accents and
inflections in these people's voices in
this movie now similar to Anakin's
growing dark feelings another important
thing that really needs to sell in this
movie is the romance between Padme and
Anakin and it just doesn't because it's
so stale their first kiss there's no
chemistry and one of the reasons the
kiss doesn't work is because never once
in the film so far has Padme even
remotely hinted at reciprocating
Anakin's Creeper love and now Lucas
continues to prove how excellent he is a
choosing child actors because he hired
this person to play Boba Fett it's your
father
yep may we see him
sure I don't even have the energy to go
into that right now
I really don't so OB 1 now reports some
of his findings to mace windu and Yoda
who are still sitting around in a room
doing nothing I think it is time we
informed the Senate that our ability to
use the force is diminished now I do
enjoy most things about the fight
between Obi one and Jango Fett it's
pretty cool especially when the only one
just jumps in the air and kicks Jango
felt like it's Mortal Kombat but the
worst part of this scene and I laugh
every time it's hilarious is when
obi-wan just keeps getting blown up over
and over again like the explosions occur
like right in front of him no scarring
of any kind nothing no injuries really
explosions just keep occurring right in
front of his face he just flies back
like oh it's so good this funny moments
in this fight like where he says oh not
good and it gets dragged around I mean
it's good stuff mostly
now obi-wan is following boba and Jango
Fett in their ship and they're about to
approach an asteroid field now one of
the things I love about this scene is
the sound effect for the seismic charges
that yeah mmm like it's a great sound
effect I've loved it ever since I first
saw the movie but what I hate about the
scene is they're now entering an
asteroid field okay
two little ships going into an asteroid
field what other Star Wars movie had an
asteroid field seen that would be the
Empire Strikes Back do you remember how
they set up that scene do you remember
how everyone was terrified
how han and Leia were like I don't know
about this this is a horrible idea
they'd be crazy to follow us wouldn't
they and see three bills like sure so
the odds of surviving an asteroid filled
a lot my buddies like never tell me the
odds and they go into the asteroid field
and that tension is built up because
they set it up as a scary event
something that is hard to do that
requires a lot of skill what happens in
Episode two
there's asteroids mm-hmm they're going
inside of them no tension no suspense no
build-up nothing just lets fly in the
asteroid field we can do it we're
perfect so Anakin starts having these
nightmares about his mother
being in pain he says that Jedi don't
have nightmares
apparently why I mean why can't Jedi
it's like Lucas spent 30 years trying to
think of all the things that Jedi can
and can't do because they're not people
they're robots they can't have love they
don't have nightmares they just sit
around in rooms and talk that's what
Jedi's do and re watching this movie
right around here I just want to turn it
off I don't want to watch it anymore I
don't want to I'm done I don't but I sat
there and I watch the rest of the movie
we meet Count Dooku now this should have
been a very dark and scary experience
instead we get this older gentleman
sitting behind the table talking to
people that's Count Dooku he's just like
this cool guys nice older man looks
handsome you know I'm the table talking
that's Count Dooku the best scene in the
film by far is Anakin holding his dead
mother in his arms as she dies his anger
the explosion against the Tusken Raiders
it's great stuff Lucas really captured
that really well but it's cut short it's
too short the scene ends it seemed like
they were still trying to go for that PG
rating which was very unfortunate
because that scene it was like okay you
got me you got oh it's over okay but the
sight of Anakin carrying his dead mother
conveys the pain of his loss very well
Lucas did a really good job with that
aspect of the movie but he also undos
some of that effectiveness with the next
scene in which Hayden Christensen
delivers his lines about how much he
hates Tusken Raiders and about how their
animals and I thought of them like
animals but not just the men but the
women and the children too
I hate them so obi-wan is captured by
Count Dooku who then tells obi-wan that
Darth Sidious is controlling the Senate
and Obi Wan's like no no no my buddies
on the Jedi Council would totally be
aware of that
Espie Kenobi not these guys now they're
they're dumb and if you thought the
Senate meeting scenes were unbearable in
the Phantom Menace this time around we
get to see Jar Jar involved in them and
he gives emergency powers to Palpatine
you know what that means Jar Jar Binks
the little fucking rabbit is basically
responsible for the downfall of the Jedi
and the rise of the Empire Thank You
Lucas you know what you're doing you
really know what you're doing don't you
you really had that one in mind didn't
you he just wanted to drive that in a
little deeper just apron there with the
Jar Jar so we get to the conveyor belt
scene which basically just looks like
Anakin twirling his lightsaber around in
some kind of dance move for the majority
of the scene Padme is stuck in a barrel
somewhere while Anakin twirls his
lightsaber around against CGI robots and
strange things now apparently Lucas
actually came up with the scene at the
very last second and kind of shot it on
the fly
now Spielberg did something very similar
with the plane fight sequence in Raiders
of the Lost Ark but that scene worked
because of its simplicity this scene
just has way too much stuff going on and
it basically just looks like two people
dodging a bunch of CGI elements if you
want to see a good conveyor belt scene
check out Minority Report oddly they
both have moments in which our hero gets
his arm caught in something and they
both came out in 2002 and Steven
Spielberg and George Lucas are friends
connections now we finally get the scene
in which Padme confesses her love to
Anakin by saying I truly deeply loved
you because that's what people say to
people who they're in love with and of
course rather than just killing them
while they have them captured they set
up this elaborate gladiator like
battlefield in which they are forced to
fight against various creatures now some
of this scene works really well I like
how there's not a lot of music at first
there's some good humor there but it's
kind of stupid how the only injury in
this scene is purposely just made to
Padme to reveal her belly because she's
supposed to be sexy in this one so
finally we get some kind of something
happening a whole bunch a Jedi just
decide you know what hey we should
probably contribute because there's like
500 of us and we should probably do
something I mean finally and Lucas
continues his tradition of killing off
FET characters and very abrupt ways when
mace windu cuts off Jango Fett's head
and he just had to put three POS head on
a robot body throughout this scene you
know for comic relief to be completely
honest my fondest memories of this scene
don't even involve the movie they
involve the game Star Wars the Clone
Wars which I enjoyed playing and one
young Boba Fett picks up Django's head I
always just expected his head to just go
like plop like right out from the helmet
I mean that's where his head is right
he'd cut off his head the head didn't
roll out of the helmet it's in the
helmet shouldn't just kind of fall out
and be like this horrific thing the kid
just gonna plop off as my dad's head
oh I'm gonna be evil and avenge him as I
was watching this movie
slowly but surely I began to think I was
watching Who Framed Roger Rabbit you
know a movie in which real people
interact with cartoons cos seeing mace
windu in this blue screen environment
just flailing his purple lightsaber
everywhere and then talking to a
floating CGI Yoda and looking at
creatures that don't exist I'm just like
is this really just a cartoon with some
real people in there every once in a
while and next we get what is hands down
the worst lightsaber fight in the entire
saga even if there wasn't anything of
real internal emotional conflict going
on in the Phantom Menace fight it was at
least really cool to look at with good
choreography and Darth Maul this one has
all these awkward shots of them just
twirling lightsabers above their heads
close-ups in this strange attempt at
some kind of art film moment and of
course the obvious Count Dooku stunt
double now Yoda shows up let's talk
about that he takes his lightsaber he
starts jumping around and flipping and
everything is nuts people loved it for
some reason some people really liked
that scene I don't know why it's one of
the dumbest moments in the entire saga
what does Yoda say in the Empire Strikes
Back he says the force is not about
muscle this crude matter here no I start
about that remember that it's not about
your lightsaber it's not about flailing
around I'm about doing fucking barrel
rolls in the air no barrel roll no
barrel roll
use the boot to take use the boots to
get through you have becoming a better
pilot so hacking the pad may get married
the end yeesh to be completely honest
Attack of the Clones is actually my
least favorite film in the entire saga
yes it doesn't have as much Jar Jar and
yes Jake Lloyd isn't in it but it's
replaced with another person whose
horrible is Anakin as well and at least
Phantom Menace didn't have any of that
awkward cringe-worthy romantic dialogue
and it at least had Darth Maul as well
this doesn't even have Darth Maul the
lightsaber fight doesn't even work
nothing about tacular clones works that
being said you can still watch it as a
Star Wars movie I'm gonna give it the
same grade that I gave Phantom Menace
even though I like it less Star Wars
Episode two attack of the clones gets a
c-minus also I want to give a huge thank
you to Piatt Michael for helping me out
with his brilliant George Lucas
impersonation I was so thrilled when he
said he would help with this video
here's a presentation from him you have
just experienced unimpressionable
Michael that's right I did the
impression of George Lucas and I had fun
collaborating with Chris if you enjoyed
that impression head on over to my
channel poke to chef P okay e da CH EF
and you'll see a whole bunch of other
impressions I guarantee it
over here I've sort of been stuck
quantized so guys I hope you enjoyed my
review of episode 2 I'm gonna be back
next month with my review of episode 3
and if you missed my review of Phantom
Menace that's on my channel right now
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuff my nice